- WE KIND OF ARE.
YEAH, DEFINITELY.
- I'M MICHELANGELO.
- YEAH, YOU DEFINITELY
ARE MICHELANGELO!
- PARTY, DUDE.
- YES.
- I'M RAPHAEL. COOL BUT RUDE.
- OH, NAILED IT.
- YEP,
DEFINITELY RUDE.
- THAT'S A CHARACTER FLAW,
BUT I'LL TAKE IT, YOU KNOW?
- HOW'S IT LOOK?
- WHOA, HOW'D YOU DO THAT?
- YEAH.
- OH, I JUST CHEWED IT
WITH MY, UH, VAMPIRE TEETH.
- REALLY?
- OH, YEAH.
- WELL, LET'S SEE.
SO WE GOT OUR NICE MIKE
OVER THERE.
WE GOT RUDE RAPH.
- YEAH, RUDE RAPH.
- SO I GUESS, UH,
I'M LEONARDO,
THE...L--
KATANA DUDE?
- NO.
DEFINITELY NOT.
- NO,
YOU'RE NOT LEONARDO.
DON'T COMPLIMENT YOURSELF
SO MUCH.
- NICE TRY, THOUGH.
YOU'RE DEFINITELY DONATELLO.
OH, HE'S SO DONATELLO!
- OH,
YOU'RE SO DONATELLO.
- DONATELLO'S, LIKE, A NERD.
AND LIKE, HE--
HE'S LIKE A PARTY POOPER.
- YEAH.
- THAT'S BASICALLY--
- THAT'S 100% WHO YOU ARE.
- IT'S ANDERS-TELLO.
THAT'S YOU.
- OH, YEAH. ANDERS-TELLO.
- YOU JUST DESCRIBED HIM.
- VERY GOOD. PLUS,
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE A MASK.
SO HOW COULD YOU BE
A NINJA TURTLE?
- WELL, YOU DIDN'T
STEAL ME A MASK!
- YOU COULD'VE STOLE
YOURSELF A MASK, MAN.
- WHOA. ENTER DONATELLO,
THE BUMMER DUDE.
JUST TAKE YOUR LITTLE COMPUTER
OUT AND PLAY WITH IT, DONATELLO.
- MAYBE I WILL.
- CHECK OUT SOME FACTS.
- FULL BAGEL BITE IN HERE.
- OH!
- UGH!
THEY'RE HARD TO DIGEST,
EVIDENTLY.
[opera music]
♪
- I CAN'T BE LEONARDO,
WHY DON'T I JUST
COVER MY BODY IN HAIR
AND CALL MYSELF SPLINTER, HUH?
HOW DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK, HUH?
- I KNEW IT!
- I'VE BEEN USING IT
FOR WEEKS, BUDDY.
IT FEELS GREAT.
SMELLS EVEN BETTER.
- I KNOW.
YOUR HAIR SMELLS DELICIOUS,
AND I'VE NOTICED THAT.
[snaps fingers]
AND I COULD TELL
THAT YOU WERE USING IT
'CAUSE YOU HAVE A BALD SPOT.
- NO, I DON'T.
- YOU'VE SEEN HIS BALD SPOT.
- I JUST WANTED MY HAIR THICKER
AND SMELLING BETTER.
- YOU'RE BALD,
JUST LIKE DONATELLO.
- THEY'RE ALL BALD.
- NO, ACTUALLY,
THEY ALL SHAVED THEIR HEADS
TO SUPPORT HIM WHILE
HE WAS FIGHTING CANCER.
- THAT'S SO NICE
OF THE OTHER DUDES,
SUPPORTING HIM WHILE
HE HAS CANCER--
- YOU ARE GETTIN' SNOPESED!
- OH, SNOPES ME, DERS!
PLEASE SNOPES ME.
- I GET NO BARS IN HERE.
- OH, YOUR MACHINE DOESN'T WORK,
DOES IT, DONATELLO?
- YOU REALLY HAD TO STEAL
FROM ME, HUH, BRO?
- WHATEVER, MAN.
- YOU WANT SOME OF MY MONEY?
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT?
YOU WANT SOME OF MY MONEY?
THERE'S A DOLLAR.
HERE ARE SOME ROCKS.
THERE'S A NICKEL.
- AND A LIMITED EDITION
LAP HOG
X.L. CONDOM!
ADAM, YOU BURGLED ME, DUDE?
- TOLD YOU.
- I'M SORRY, BLAKE.
YOU DON'T NEED IT.
I NEED IT.
GOD BLESSED/CURSED ME
WITH A THIGH-SLAPPER,
AND I NEED AN X.L. CONDOM
TO PACKAGE THE WHOLE THING.
- OH, YEAH, RIGHT.
COME ON, MAN. I'VE SEEN IT.
IT'S NOT THAT BIG.
- NO, YOU'RE--
- I WALK IN ON HIM
JERKIN' OFF ALL THE TIME.
- IT IS THAT BIG.
DEAL WITH IT.
I'VE GOT AN ED HELMS.
- NEWS FLASH, EVERYBODY--
FRIENDS DO NOT STEAL
FROM OTHER FRIENDS.
THAT'S, LIKE,
A BASIC RULE.
- I DIDN'T WANNA HAVE
TO DO THIS, BLAKE.
BUT TAKE OFF YOUR PANTS.
- EW, NO.
- I SAW...
WHEN WE WERE CHICKEN FIGHTING,
YOUR UNDERWEARS.
TAKE OFF YOUR PANTS
RIGHT NOW!
- DON'T DO THIS.
- TAKE YOUR PANTS OFF.
- AND DON'T MAKE ME USE
MY MUSCLES 'CAUSE I'LL USE 'EM.
- [sighs]
- YEP.
THERE YOU GO.
- MY BREATHABLE MESH JOCKEYS?
- YEAH. HE STOLE YOUR UNDERWEAR.
- DUDE!
- SO YOU'RE ALSO A THIEF.
POT CALLING THE KETTLE...
UH...
- BLACK.